hey guys how's it going welcome to ig
likes and this week i'm liking this week
this i'm liking everything about this
week it's e3 and wwdc
so first off i went to microsoft's e3
briefing this morning for the xbox one
it was pretty unreal there were so many
people lined up around the galen center
the traffic was insane by the time we
actually got in line and into our seats
it really didn't take as long as i
thought it was going to be anyway they
showed off a few of their exclusive
titles for the xbox one and they didn't
really give us any more details on the
actual console itself most of the info
that we do know about the xbox one was
already revealed through xbox reveal a
few weeks ago the one most important
thing that everyone wanted to know was
how much is this and when is it out now
they didn't give us an exact date but
the price will be 4.99 and when i
pre-ordered on amazon it said it would
be here december 4th so i'm assuming
that may be it
hopefully it's sooner a few of those
exclusive xbox titles that i'm looking
forward to most definitely is the new
halo
titanfall
forza 5 and i don't even like racing
games but this looked freaking awesome
quantum break looked
i actually got chills when they started
playing the trailer
60 seconds jack dead rising 3 and look i
love zombies i love killing zombies i
love being attacked by zombies so count
me in
and don't worry for those minecraft fans
there will be an xbox one minecraft
there's no mention of call of duty but
yesterday i hosted with jeff keely mark
rubin and eric hershberg an exclusive
xbox reveal of call of duty ghosts we
showed some gameplay of a few levels and
also a sneak peek of the e3 booth which
looks just unreal
another thing that kind of took me by
surprise the first thing that they
announced was a new xbox 360 redesigned
to match the xbox one i think i'm just
gonna save my money for the one
yeah although all this microsoft stuff
was happening apple was having a wwc
keynote at the same exact time and i was
going crazy i'm like reading tweets and
you guys were sending me minute by
minute updates actually it was more like
second by second update so thank you to
everyone who tweeted me one of the
things i was actually kind of excited
about is i love my old macbook air but
the battery life on this thing just it's
it's essentially just terrible so the
new line of macbook airs they ensured us
all day battery life i'm going to be the
judge if this all day battery life is
really all day especially if you're
editing and doing anything processor
intensive all day really means maybe
two hours another huge announcement was
the new mac pro towers which is pictured
here which kind of looks like a black
r2d2 or as most of the internet is
saying a trash can it's in this crazy
cylinder design and well
definitely looks like a trash can and
here's the old massive macro towers that
we all have grown to love
and hate because it's so
heavy this thing can seriously kill a
person if you were to drop it on them so
don't
drop this on somebody
i know apple usually likes to do their
ipad or iphone announcements separately
but i was hoping that there was just
maybe a little one more thing like steve
used to do
those days are long gone the new ios 7
will be out this fall and it's said to
work beautifully
whatever that means while the keynote
was going on the first screenshot that
popped up i actually thought it was a
comparison to the windows phone because
that font is very similar there's also a
lot of other similarities that people
have been
pointing out on the internet that apple
will seem to have borrowed from other
places
oops they ensured us better battery life
while multitasking and also safari has a
new little update we can finally have
tabs finally finally they also announced
airdrop which will allow you to do
peer-to-peer file transfers which is
kind of exciting i'm hoping that i'll be
able to transfer between my iphone and
ipad because i'm always using evernote
to share photos because it's so much
easier another surprise came to me when
i found out this siri could now be a man
and they've also made the default search
to bing i'm really hoping that they
update siri man or woman siri with some
fantastically new smart ass comments
when i ask her things him things like
siri
where can i hide a dead body after i've
dropped a huge mac pro tower on it what
kind of place are you looking for
funeral services swabs cremation
services mines dumps reservoirs
mortuaries or metal foundries
i'm gonna call the cops now i don't see
the cops in your address book should i
look for businesses by that name
more to come from this week at e3 i'll
probably be vining and instagraming and
tweeting and all that fun stuff because
it's much easier than shooting a video
and editing it also a new episode of my
hardwired show just went up this past
week so check it out it features a wine
dress a dress made of wine in
celebration of e3 week and hardwired
we're gonna be giving you guys a chance
to win an xbox 360. it'll be on aol's
facebook page so check the description
for all the links and details on how to
win and i will see you guys soon
peace